even the TSA admits to the slog of
airport security and they say they want
to make it better they're offering
rewards totaling about $15,000 for the
best ideas for making the line go faster
well video contest they ain't really my
kind of hobby above 15 grand you're
cutting checks like your name was
Slovakia but if you're asking for some
tips I've got a couple rules to make the
lines even shorter than me wants to get
in the school and just because it zips
up don't make them take their best off
if they just had a mastectomy don't make
them take their breasts off if you're
looking for another tip to save a couple
minutes into shrinking for their mom or
when you grow them they're not
terrorists assaulting children's never
good and it's safe to assume the only
time it's okay is if your name's Orlando
Bloom and if
for even more time I swear you'll have
enough different people go through TSA
you don't do any other stuff you'd save
time if the guy with the ID check in
place of the district of columbia's in
the United States can bring apples on
board or a crate of McIntosh you could
save some time by not arresting ladies
you bring apples sonic an old folks take
their pants off how is that embarrassing
well the answer to both questions just
happens to be depends if someone fought
in Korea facing full of death and strife
maybe that should be the most dramatic
thing they go through in their line now
at this point I realize that offering
this dollar though their fights will
likely lead to you checking me for
polyps but if you think it's no you send
my entries gone awry like a rape victim
that gets pat-down all I can do is